last night on that uh that last dance
episodes 3 & 4 is on Dennis Rodman and
during the middle of the season he just
like I need a break
I'm sickness I need a break and Michael
Jordan and Phil Jackson I call right to
take it well let you do you be back in
48 hours
go to Vegas come back because I need to
go to Vegas just on his motorcycle
cruises to Vegas his growth times Carmen
Electra so he's out there just doing
crank out Lord's work but Carmen Electra
is honestly is on the documentary like
currently yeah dude she is a smoke she
so looking god but I work with her Bubba
yes smoosh I work with her and she's
she's a great person she was so [ __ ]
good she had to beat me up in fat
actress and I just I have nothing but
good Wow good for her nearly shoulder
nice looking good dude she was it
remembers you either a karma lecture or
Pamela and Cynthia I like both I work
with both spending week with both
because that's on spend spend a week
with both ladies good cremeluxe were
very pretty and an awesome person Pam
Anderson it wasn't cool best of all time
oh I'm personally better-looking in
person oh well oh kill you and cool
both I'm really cool actually I have to
say but Conor electro looks so much
better than Pam Anderson now probably
seen Pam lately no you got up just she
had hep-c and she went through treatment
no saying all that I'm Saint current
physical yeah well you know listen age
as a [ __ ] dude but when she was
younger forget it well I said I still
take Carmen Electra man no one currently
I mean Pam's not bad yeah they're got
Pam was a sexy diamond piece oxidize
ridiculous yeah so he's a criminal extra
fan though but she was smokin dude my
girlfriend at the time was friends with
her a little bit and she came out she
just dresses like she just has no
problem dressing like a complete
stripper like she would just they'd go
out and she'd be wearing basically pasty
he's practically got it I know but she
was really cool the account Electra said
because Rodman is only supposed to gun
for 48 hours and Michael Jordan told
Phil Jackson like dude he's not he's
gonna be gone way long forty hours
and feels like now he'll be back sure
enough four days go past he's and he's
still in Vegas so Jordan flew out there
and knocked on his hotel door Jordan
yeah and Carmen Electra said she was so
scared she hid but she's she's I was
naked so I put a sheet over my head and
just hid where he can't see me and my
cousin was like get your ass to [ __ ]
practice really yeah so so I always
wondered about that relationship because
I know Jordan ran all those
[ __ ] I mean you'd hear him in
games like are you afraid you wanna win
you know but I feel like yeah he'd say
he said it afraid you got a little wish
he'd say he said that he goes are you
afraid you want to win because I'm not I
win here yeah there's a thing I know it
sounds silly but he actually screamed
wants to win everything is a white guy
from Serbia one of those guys so but my
question is I never saw him it seemed
like he never he and Robin and kind of
avoided each other like no holes uh-huh
really
no they were pretty calm it was wild
everywhere else especially when he went
to San Antonio it was good on Detroit
you won the same Detroit and then he got
traded and when he went to the Bulls
right he was like Rodman I'm Jordan pip
and we're so respectable and like knew
Rodman was gonna be this loose cannon
but as long as performed they were cool
yeah so ramen was good yeah cuz he let
them really buddy because he knew his
job and he knew Jordan Scottie word
because he didn't need the ball he
didn't want to score he didn't want to
rebound freak I forgot it's interesting
man because they show all the guys you
know currently and then they show on the
plane
everybody thick Wow here but it's the
age errbody thing yeah you enjoy like
damned I got a gut no yeah that's
Michael Jordan the great bald on you
looking like what struck me was how
South thin he was when he was playing
when he first got gone this all out of
college is just so skinny like they put
thing get started lifting put on weight
yeah yeah but man and and when you see
his speed I've never seen that high
speed it was so with such a different
speed it was like mikkel he would get
called to the trash-zilla Brahmas I know
he'd get called for traveling because he
was so fast all the time
here's a thin dude cat interesting
what's funny is that episode 1 and 2
everyone's feeling sorry for Scottie
Pippen fYI he made more money than
Jordan over his NBA career look it's
right here
LeBron Trey young settles the goat
debate click on that for me for me
Jordans by far the goat just because he
so every accolade
LeBron's ever had Jordan had plus he won
that dunk contest which LeBrons too
afraid to do he doesn't want to put he
doesn't want to risk it so the best
players and they made don't do the dunk
contest anymore
because the reason I can't shirt or what
just pull I forgot that Kobe did you
I've come around
oh dude how did movie Dominic Wilkins
director Michael Jordan the best of the
best always did it yeah Larry Johnson's
car nerd yeah oh yeah the best of the
best of the superstar just do it now
everyone's too scared to get hurt
they're too scared to you know to
receive criticism they don't think
they're gonna win they don't do it
anymore
back in the day the guys did it yeah so
join one dunk contest MVP NBA MVP Finals
MVP Defensive Player of the Year so it's
like so sick LeBron's never meet defense
Player of the Year now let's do a couple
of q and a's so while many often debate
so so some said who's your best so he
said my top five LeBron James Jordan
Kobe Katie Steve Nash who is try so he
just thinks he's a really good NBA
player from played Oklahoma he's a
[ __ ] beast interesting but I think I
think if you're a younger guy you're
gonna go with LeBron James it's just
what you know it's like if you ask me
what the greatest Navy is all time mine
yeah exact my perspectives and he's so
much different than yours very true so
so much different I aboard who's the
greatest band of all time
minded me so much cats and me so much
different than chins because it depends
what area you grew up in the question is
if you have to choose one player out of
that list first my quality Michael
Jordan yeah
clutch she's defense you know heart of a
warrior yeah monster led the league and
all those things that's really important
did you see uh
you also have to take into account you
just have to the fact that Michael was
than LeBron and still was able to you
know achieve more that that physical
difference is was it Michael's not small
by the it was he was six six but Ron six
nine 265 that's a significant size
difference with great speed so
phenomenal athlete very muscular but
that dad plays a part you have an
advantage I feel like when you're that
that big in that fast
so the question yeah I wonder if the
Brahma is working with the same tools
you can't use that that's so silly
that's so silly bit yeah maybe it
doesn't make a difference after a while
that size three inches is significant
though been the goat conversational
include that it's you know yeah it does
it they have to include it you have to
how tall was Kobe six seven yeah what's
the hunk [ __ ] you're on it I can do it
at age 31
LeBron averaged 27 points my class
average 32 nowhere near as many rebounds
oh my is Michael yeah yeah he's not as
big you just a bra can get in there and
bang that's I always say who would you
rather have on your team who's who has a
greater impact who leads you to victory
I mean I'm not in you know wrong with
either tough because what LeBron did
against the Golden State Warriors on
that shitty Cleveland team and one
that's insane it's a greatest fall time
it's hard to say many thank you you know
you're never gonna win you're fine with
everybody you're never gonna win boy
I've seen Kobe in person couple times he
looks taller than six six he's a freak
Saint yummy
Charles Barkley it was six four there is
Lexie yeah
oh my lord oh yeah he's like seven four
I think oh he was a stud too for a while
he's too big so you know her boy Dennis
Rodman seems to be friends of that
[ __ ] guy and that weird that's such
an unlikely friendship it's so weird
when they asked Rodman about like all
the horrible stuff he's like listen I
don't touch on that I don't know about
me and that's though he starts a lot of
bad stuff too and yeah it's tough seeing
Robin two men and it was
he's definitely weird yeah all the
piercings in his nose he's always had
that though even when he's playing at
the Pistons Liv knows but I heard that
he he went crazy once his son he had he
lost custody of son is it yeah I truly
crazy
always always he has a color thing with
his face - yeah that's impetigo it looks
like he's moving he's losing something
Wow is that the same as a bit of like Oh
father time um yes that's what I mean
it's I think it's a bit alike oh I don't
know if that's true but that's what it
looks like but he likes to dress and
drag sort of rock cast with him oh
that's I supposed to a podcast oh I know
I committed to it and then there's in
Newport and this is when there's bad
traffic I was like yet new not I looked
at the arrival it was like you know they
take me two and a half hours to get
there I'll scour well let me just see
what's podcasts about I don't if he's
still doing it it was it was him giving
relationship advice and having two
couples on I was like what are we don't
wanna be part of this man I don't know
if they're still doing it
no he is such a character he is such a
character
yeah I was wondering what guys like that
do on a day to day basis you know like
well you know he made so much money
hopefully they're good there but then
yeah but I mean I just [ __ ] love them
what is this on why not my outfit that's
a great beetlejuice good I really him
yeah looks like Wow damn was the teeth
Wow yeah just a different bird he is a
different bird man he's a different bird
you'll actually shake it up I'll tell
you this right now yeah yeah yeah yeah
watch your tongue oh good what's gonna
happen what are you gonna do use some of
that boxing you've been doing
[Laughter]